is it in a pretty functional process a
drop of 4 100 page bill this morning
expect to vote on it tomorrow but most
of Congress hasn't had a chance to
review look the bill has been carefully
worked on by the Appropriations
Committee for a very very long time most
of the provisions of the bill were well
known weeks and weeks and weeks in
advance and getting this bill done for
the American people which really matters
is the most important thing he is not
for the American people McConnell is not
for the American people if I'm an
American you you people have nothing to
do with any of the things that I believe
in they're making more of an argument
for Trump than Trump can make for
himself that's really what's going on
here it's incredible what these people
are doing but 2 A.M Tuesday release you
know who else does that when Google and
Apple update your terms of service and
they tell you subtly that you're going
to lose some rights or some free speech